[Musique]
je rêve d'une société où les femmes
prennent de plus en plus de décisions
politiques
je rêve d'une société le salaire des
peurs et celui des oeuvres est égal
c'est au théâtre saint gilles qui a eu
le premier concours régional d'éloquence
du titre souvenirs je pense à vous
madame simone veil 13 finalistes se sont
affrontés pour chacun de 6 à 10 minutes
de joutes verbales sur la thématique
d'une gravité réelle la violence
intrafamiliale
aujourd'hui j'ai des cibles je décide
d'être la femme libre et intelligente
qui ne sert pas qu'à la cuisiner par le
ménage devant un jury composé de
personnalités du délégué régional de
directeur et d'élus du département
il juge les mots des expressions on
appelle ça l'éloquence c'est vraiment un
honneur d'être parmi vous et participer
à ce jury pour le concours de
l'éloquence le conseil départemental
quelque part près par ces jeunes à ce
concours d'éloquence et on a le plaisir
d'avoir avec nous ce soir un jeune
conseiller départemental jeunes qui
jusqu'au bout avec les lakers
lorsqu'il s'est présenté pour être
président il ya un poster sa candidature
pour être président et conseillers
jeunes et concours d'éloquence se font
de plus en plus nombreux et le
département de la réunion encourage ce
concours très populaire et qui jouit
d'un écho grandissant et j'espère que
dans dix ans ce concours auquel j'aurais
participé ne sera plus qu'un lointain
souvenir faisant place enfin à l'égalité
merci beaucoup mesdames et messieurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]